los rehenes retenidos por extremistas
vinculados a al qaeda animal y fueron
liberados según las autoridades
malienses lo que estalló mediáticamente
en twitter fue que tanto la francesa
sophie y petrona como el político
maliense soumaila cissé ya estaban en
camino a la libertad el presidente
manuel macrón agradeció a mali sophie
petro con janis está libre retenida
durante cuatro años su liberación es un
gran alivio a su familia y parientes les
envió un mensaje de simpatía a las
autoridades de malí gracias continúa la
lucha contra el terrorismo en el sahel
también fueron liberados dos italianos
incluido un sacerdote secuestrado en
níger hace dos años petronan una
trabajadora humanitaria de 75 años
dirigió una organización benéfica para
niños huérfanos y fue secuestrada en el
norte de mali en 2016
el político maliense soumaila cissé
también fue capturado el ex ministro que
se postuló dos veces a la presidencia
fue secuestrado mientras hacía campaña
en marzo de este año esto alimentó las
protestas contra el presidente del país
ibrahim abu bakr keita cuyo segundo
mandato llegó a su fin después de que
fue derrocado por los militares en
agosto la liberación se produce después
de que el ejército de mali
que ahora está a cargo de la transición
hacia un gobierno civil liberará a unos
130 extremistas durante el fin de semana
varios países de áfrica occidental han
levantado las sanciones que le habían
impuesto a mali después de que keita fue
derrocado